ok uno dei più grandi misteri della
scienza e
ma anche i misteri e che hanno
terrorizzato tutte le popolazioni e
l'invecchiamento e la mortalità la morte
e forse non c'è posto più che che los
angeles che rappresenta questo questa
voglia questa preoccupazione questa
voglia di rimanere eternamente giovani
il quando era ancora uno studente che
studiava jazz all'università del texas
un giorno ho deciso di dismettere con la
musica o almeno di cambiare strada e
perché ho proprio pensato a questa cosa
dell'invecchiamento come che invecchiamo
e interessante era il fatto che tutti mi
dicevano los angeles quindi los angeles
era la mecca al tempo di queste di
questi studi sull'invecchiamento e
particolarmente perché c'era questo
centro landus gerontologia center ha
diretto da calebb finch che si
specializzava già da 50 anni fa proprio
su questa su questa materia
l'invecchiamento perché invecchiamo ed
era un centro che faceva sia didattica
che ricerca proprio sull'invecchiamento
e adesso questo è il centro dove sono
attualmente dove il mio laboratorio e il
problema quando abbiamo iniziato quando
io ho iniziato in questo campo
dell'invecchiamento il problema del del
campo era questo tipo di studi molto
basati su biologia comparativa per
esempio neanche molto basati su opinioni
e quindi questo ad esempio è uno slide
di una donna che al tempo di los angeles
che al tempo aveva 115 anni quindi aveva
il record della
di vita e questa signora pensava e
comunque diceva raccontare i giornalisti
che lei era così longeva perché a non
fumava perché aveva fatto una vita molto
regolata e questo è molto diverso invece
da madame calmante in francia che invece
ha raggiunto un'età di 122 anni
madan calmante come vedete a differenza
della signora di los angeles aveva
fumato addirittura fino a 100 anni e
aveva smesso non per problemi di salute
ma aveva smesso perché era imbarazzata
del fatto che non riusciva più
accendersi la sigaretta e quindi questo
era un po il diciamo lo stato del figlio
della condizione all'inizio degli anni
90 non sapevamo cos'era l'invecchiamento
tante speculazioni tante opinioni
allora quello che che forse ha cambiato
un po le cose che ha portato a un'unione
almeno delle opinioni di molti è stata
la genetica dell'invecchiamento perché
la genetica perché usando sistemi molto
semplici
praticamente siamo riusciti ad avere
delle vere dimostrazioni di che cos'era
l'invecchiamento quali erano i geni che
contro l'invecchiamento e la vera
dimostrazione era proprio l'allungamento
della vita
se riesce allunga la vita di un
organismo st devi per forza influenzare
il suo invecchiamento e quindi noi con a
lieviti del panettiere ayusya lei e
altri harvard e mariti e hugh sia surf
con drosophila anche altri che
lavoravano sul lievito e i nematodi
usavano queste tecniche molto potenti
queste tecniche che ha praticamente
sfruttavano il l'abilità di modificare
il dna e quindi di creare delle
mutazioni nel dna di questi organismi
per vedere che cos'è la quale era il
gene
all le vie di segnalazioni che
promuovevano la protezione cellulare e
l'allungamento della vita e per esempio
noi avevamo dimostrato che il questa
mutazione in questa via di segnalazione
di questo gene che risponde alla
presenza di proteine di aminoacidi che
si chiama torre esses canese triplicava
la vita e addirittura in combinazione
con altre mutazioni riusciva a estendere
la vita di ben 10 volte e questo queste
vie di segnalazioni poi sono state
confermate il ruolo di queste vie
nell'invecchiamento è stato confermato
poi in nematodi e moscerini della frutta
eccetera e allo stesso tempo il
laboratorio di andrei barchi e jean cap
cic stavano lavorando su questi topi a
su questi topi nani questi topi nani che
al tempo non sapevamo avessero lo stesso
tipo di mutazione perché in effetti i
geni erano diversi da questi topi nani
vivevano il 40 per cento in più
e questi topi oltre a vivere di più
avevano un la metà delle malattie quindi
topi che vivono molto di più e hanno la
metà delle malattie e poi pian piano
siamo arrivati a capire che queste vie
di segnalazione del di questi topi a cui
mancava il ricettore dell'ormone di
crescita
erano le stesse o erano associate a
quelle che noi avevamo scoperto che
invece agivano in maniera intracellulare
infatti non stranamente sia i lieviti
mutanti longevi che a cui manca questa
torre e si scanners pathway che questi
topi e qui manca il recettore
dell'ormone di crescita sono nani quindi
hanno dei grossi difetti nelle vie di
segnalazione che hanno a che fare con la
crescita con la crescita cellulare e
anche con la crescita a corporea allora
è a questo punto sapevamo
che questo tipo di mutazione che parte
dai nutrienti della dieta e che poi
influenza la crescita dell'organismo la
crescita cellulare la che se lo iorismo
sono centrali per l'invecchiamento
iniziavamo anche grazie ai lavori sia
nosti del lievito che quegli altri di
sindia canyon e andre i barchini world
nematodi e nei moscerini sapevamo che
c'era anche una forte protezione contro
le mafie
quello che non sapevamo è che tutti
volevano sapere era quale era l'effetto
di questo su sugli uomini allora assi
cohen sia lei a circa dieci anni fa mi
ha detto che c'era questa popolazione
nelle montagne del sud dell'ecuador che
aveva che aveva proprio questa mutazione
la stessa mutazione di questi topi
longevi e questi topi protetti da
malattie
allora abbiamo iniziato la ricerca circa
sette otto anni fa proprio in queste in
queste montagne dell ecuador dove aimi
guevara che noi chiamiamo j guevara e
stava seguendo circa 100 di questi
individui che sono praticamente
l'equivalente umano di questi topi
longevi aimi li seguiva già da molti
anni era infatti il suo medico medico il
suo il loro il loro e medico
endocrinologo e quindi abbiamo cercato
di capire se in effetti queste persone
erano longeve e anche se queste persone
erano protette dalle malattie
la prima cosa è stata che in effetti non
c'era la longevità
che ci aspettavamo almeno dai topi
quindi questi uomini non vivevano
tipicamente il 30 40 per cento in più
dei loro parenti e probabilmente un po
di più e questo non è ancora chiaro
comunque sicuramente hanno una vita
normale quello che invece è stato molto
e molto promettente e il fatto che
quando abbiamo controllato il loro
livello di malattie particolarmente di
abb il diabete e il cancro
sembravano altamente protetti da queste
due malattie e infatti pur essendo obesi
avendo una prevalenza di obesità che di
gran lunga superiore a quella dei loro
parenti
senza questa mutazione il loro livello
di diabete e per ora almeno in queste
100 persone nessuno ha mai sviluppato il
diabete contro il 5 per cento più o meno
di prevalenza nei loro parenti
quindi e come si vede anche
dall'insulina questi mutanti
queste persone con mutazioni nel ricetta
dell'armani di crescita hanno una bassa
basso livello di insulina quindi sono
altamente o almeno sembrano essere
altamente protetti dal diabete e questa
è la stessa osservazione che è stata
fatta anche nei topi quindi molto
incoraggiante questa quest'abbinamento e
poi come vi ho già detto il cancro in
rosso in questo slide 20 per cento nella
popolazione dei loro parenti quindi qui
stavamo guardando quanti dei parenti di
questi mutanti di queste persone muoiono
di cancro è il più o meno il 20 per
cento che sa che diciamo quello che ci
si aspetta in base alla popolazione
dell'acqua dovrei anche alla popolazione
del nord america e invece nei in questi
laroni questi pazienti con queste
mutazioni nessuna morte di cancro almeno
negli ultimi 50 anni che che abbiamo
potuto che abbiamo potuto misurare
allora questi laron questi pazienti sono
potenzialmente parzialmente longevi ma
sicuramente protetti almeno da alcune
delle malattie dell'invecchiamento
ok questo tipo di ricerca
lo scopo finale eventualmente sarà
quello di identificare farmaci e altre e
altre
interventi che possono causare le stesse
gli stessi effetti di queste mutazioni
adesso invece quello che è che possiamo
già fare è capire come aveva detto
queste vie di segnalazione che controlla
invecchiamento sono controllate da i
nutrienti nella dieta e in particolare
il le proteine ad esempio la carne
controllano la via di segnalazione della
torre sisca nesi quella che vi ho detto
che nel lievito triplica la vita e il i
carboidrati almeno nel lievito e adesso
pensiamo che lo stesso succede nel nel
nei mammiferi controllano la seconda via
di segnalazione che la raspi che ai
teatri che controlla l'invecchiamento
quindi carboidrati e proteine sono
responsabili per questa spinta a le vie
pro invecchiamento e walford che già nel
92 era diventato il mio primo capo
diciamo del dottorato era aveva già
capito questa cosa non aveva gli non
aveva
it was non aveva le possibilità di
studiare le cose che noi abbiamo
studiato perché queste tecnologie sono
note molto dopo ma avrà già capito chi
era la restrizione calorica e quindi
diminuzione di carne diminuzione di
carboidrati e anche di grassi che
allungava la vita umana e il watford era
già 50 anni che lavorava su questa cosa
direi in effetti uno dei pionieri di
questa restrizione calorica quindi una
riduzione delle calorie del 20 30 per
cento allungava la vita di topi d
di una varietà di organismi e walford
credeva così tanto in questa strategia
che si era rinchiuso insieme ad altre
sette persone nella in questa sistema
incluso chiamato biosfera 2 questa
biosfera 2 che era un una città nel
mezzo del deserto dell'arizona ed erano
rimasti due anni in questa in questo
sistema sigillato la cosa straordinaria
sono i risultati adesso senza guardare i
dettagli ma i risultati straordinari ad
esempio di della pressione del sangue di
questi questi otto individui sono
entrati con una pressione del sangue di
media di 110 115 e dopo qualche mese in
esteri ristretti caloricamente questa
pressione è scesa di circa il 30 per
cento più o meno 80 85 colesterolo più
basso e trigliceridi più bassi e
un'altra è una serie di straordinari
cambiamenti dei marcatori soprattutto di
varie malattie metaboliche diabete e
malattie cardiovascolari
ok però qual era il problema il problema
era che adesso sulla sinistra e roy
watford
durante la biosfera durante il periodo
della biosfera quando era ristretto
caloricamente sulla destra eroi walford
quando è uscito era walford considerate
che era una persona molto sana e quindi
mangiava molto attentamente anche dopo
quello il punto è che la restrizione
calorica e molto severa ed è
difficilissima da gestire ed è anche
probabilmente pericolose per la maggior
parte delle persone si è fatta degree
diciamo nella severità della con cui è
stata fatta nella biosfera due allora
quali sono le vere soluzioni alla nostra
portata
questo è uno studio fatto dalla loma
linda university qualche anno fa che
faceva vedere che le
colazioni di california dentist almeno
negli uomini ma anche le donne vivevano
fino a 10 anni di più con una dieta che
era basata su vegetali molto nutritiva
quindi noci altri nutrienti
relativamente bassa in in calorie ma non
ristretta caloricamente quindi queste
erano persone che mangiavano
relativamente normalmente ma mangiavano
in una maniera molto precisa infatti non
è sorprendente che questa dieta è molto
simile alla dieta che seguono le
popolazioni più longevi al mondo
quest'anno insieme a craig uilca hsiao
chin aula proprio questa signora di 90
circa 95 anni ancora balla con questa
bottiglia enorme sulla testa da due o
tre volte la settimana e questi questa
popolazione di okinawa che la più
longeva al mondo infatti mangia in
maniera molto simile a questi california
agente e quindi calorie relativamente
basse ma una dieta principalmente
vegetariana basata su carboidrati
complessi e di nuovo e forse alcuni di
voi saranno sorpresi da questa cosa ma
il sud italia e in effetti uno dei posti
più longevi al mondo l'italia non è
possibile in jv al mondo particolarmente
su in italia dove salvatore caruso di
107 anni che vediamo qui è ancora molto
attivo ea una dieta che per contenuto è
simile a quella di okinawa
ed è anche simile a quella che abbiamo
visto prima della seven days aventis da
dei californiani quindi purtroppo la la
dignità italiana adesso si è trasformata
in una dieta molto più simile a quella
americana e nord europea con con alti
livelli di carne formaggi eccetera
e quando invece la dieta ideale è quella
un po dei nostri nonni e quindi una
dignità principalmente molto povera
principalmente basata su verde
pure ma anche molto nutritiva e ed è
questa la dieta almeno fino a che non ci
saranno altre soluzioni che a cui
probabilmente dobbiamo ritornare la
dieta che unisce scienza e tradizioni
gaza